cayó la noche en buenos aires y el
pueblo argentino siguió ahí alrededor
del obelisco en la principal avenida de
la capital argentina un pueblo que baila
canta celebra a su ídolo su diego
armando maradona
y ghana es ahora la nave es ahora se fue
argentina
hoy se murió argentina lo que él nos
hizo conocido en todo el mundo y bueno
estamos hoy representando lo porque ya
no estamos con nosotros hacen falta
muchos vivos en argentina que digan lo
que lo que le sale adentro lo que los
que no tengan filtro no soy haber otro
digo pero que no necesitamos seguro
desde el anuncio de su muerte los
argentinos han dado un giro a sus
programas siguiendo en directo el
recorrido de los restos del pibe de oro'
hasta aquí la casa rosada el palacio
presidencial en donde los argentinos
podrán rendir un último homenaje hasta
el sábado en esta madrugada del jueves
la multitud ya está presente y conmovida
dándole un adiós para la eternidad a su
querido hijo el niño del barrio pobre
celebrado donde haya pasado sus
extravagancias sus excesos sus
sobresaltos todo está olvidado sólo
cuenta el recuerdo el que trajo de
argentina un legendario mundial